Vì tổng thống Mi đường nơi trà mã thơi 3 mươi phần trang với hàng nghiệp khẩu từ EU đang tạo ra lần sống lo ngày xong dọt tại Chuao.
Theo Oro Nils, nước và Aley là hai cô gia biển hưởng năng nhất khi thẳng dứt thương mại của họ bị Mỹ là nửa tảm vi tư vậy tảm tỷ đồ và tảm vi só phía bẩy tỷ đồ là Mỹ.
Tất cả những công nghiệp ô tồ hoá chết và dược phẩm, bốn đáng vai chào chủ cầu trung tăng trường, này bị đe sóa nghiêm trọng.
Rồi giao, một viện nghiên cứu có trụ sử tảm rút sên, dự báo đứt có thể mất tới không phải bốn phần trăm trở đi bê,
nếu các mất thời kéo sài sông năm 2018, tại Pháp và Iter Lì, các ngày như hàng không, thời chang và thực phẩm,
cũng đối mặt nguy cơ lớn khi thẳng dứt thương mại với Mỹ là nửa t đặt mươi sống phía bốn và bốn mít tư tỷ đồ là Mỹ.
Chào mối kênh đó phản nướng chính chỉ từ EU đang dồn về hai hướng, ra hạp đam phán và chuẩn bị biển pháp đáp trả.
Chủ tế ngay sẻ ở số là phôn trở lên thông báo, ngoảng cơ đồng trả đối thối Mỹ cho tới thẳng sau,
khẳng định EU vẫn ưu tiên đối thoại, sông không loại trử hành động.
Thủ tưởng đức Friedrich's Muzz và tổng thống Pháp em mân mặt mặt mặt mặt mặt mặt đứa chương sẵn,
hối cần đoàn kết để bảo vệ lỗi trung.
Đây không chỉ là một cuộc chiến thế quan mà còn là bài kiểm tra sức bền của EU trong thời điểm để đến động.